[Music]
hey you guys yeah tom's talking to
pokemon yeah
danny's in the comments section saying
that the porn version of this is called
[ __ ] waves
for amber waves of cod
[Laughter]
so we saw a death ship the other day and
i said it reminded me of shockwaves so
we went ahead and watched shockwaves you
can watch shockwaves for free on
tv yeah and pluto now has a
it now has an app that you can download
for your xbox or xbox
like yeah xbox one because a couple of
years ago i remember i was like oh i
want to download a pluto app for xbox
and they didn't have one but they do
have one now yeah i got one now so
um
so we watched it and uh
it's good it's okay uh it's a florida
movie
it was uh
it was uh
filmed right here in florida yeah where
was it um
several places like a lot of the swampy
[ __ ] that was uh that was miami around
the miami area um
and uh coral gables yeah coral gables
and some of it was shot in ocala i think
as well maybe or no that's something
that's that's something else i'm
thinking of actually but yeah i think
this was mostly filmed in south florida
right right around coral gables well i
think that one yeah coral gables that's
where the hotel is that's where the host
in this movie they find this abandoned
spanish hotel it's [ __ ] awesome all
right and it's in this movie and uh
they're they're pretending like they're
on an island somewhere but that's
that's miami yeah
nowadays it's probably near a downtown
area but i don't know it's probably
still swampy because there's like all
the mangrove swamps and stuff like that
that's it's probably right around the
everglades it was on the coast
they showed it they showed it from the
coast uh or at least i think it was that
hotel looked like uh it looked like the
same building
um
but uh
we were looking at this hotel and it was
just awesome all these arches and looks
like you know it looks like old spain
and it's probably not there anymore
because it's abandoned in this movie and
this was made in the 1970s 70s it was
abandoned then and so look at the stuff
that was in there it'd say 1920s at
least like the boiler rooms and a lot of
probably 1920s oh my god the light
fixtures in that open oh my god i want
those so probably torn down because i
was we were searching it's like what
hotel
uh what hotel is that and yeah it said
it was in coral gables it says abandoned
hotel coral gables but never mentioned
the hotel so i'm imagining it's not
there anymore and honestly there's a lot
of hotels that were built around that
time period that had that same
architecture so
maybe so i i couldn't really find
anybody that knew exactly what hotel it
was so
a lot of the movie is filmed in this
hotel a lot of stuff a lot of zombie
action happens in it some of it in a
swamp outside
the movie was shot for 150 000 dollars
this is a super low budget move yeah
super cheap um so they just worked with
what they had they had
a couple of cast members that you would
recognize and um
a script and some [ __ ] dudes dressed
up like nazis nazi zombies with goggles
and [ __ ] bleach blonde hair i think
please somebody correct me if i'm wrong
i'm pretty sure
that this was the first
movie in the nazi zombie subgenre might
have been
um
i can't really think of one prior to
this and honestly i don't even know i
mean i guess like the nazis and this are
zombies but they kind of are more like
vampires
well they don't bite anybody yeah but
they are like they they can't
but how to kill them and this is a
spoiler alert how to kill them is yeah
take their goggles taking their goggles
off and they pulled that right out of
their hands
well it's like well we can't afford to
have them like go up in a puff of smoke
or anything like that this is a very
very very cheap movie now they did get
john carradine yeah who he'll be in
pretty much anything though i love you
john kerry well he's dead but i'm just
saying that i love john kerry he's a
salty old sea cat he would be in
anything
he's he's the salty old sea captain that
they hired to [ __ ]
as captain of the ship a little trip
that they're doing they're taking
passengers and the trip gets all [ __ ]
up and he tells us we're not turning
around looking you guys have paid for
passage i already spent your money spent
the money on the ship so we're going on
this cruise whether you like it or not
yeah right
and the guests on there [ __ ] their
two couples and uh
that's it and then the rest of it's the
crew
pretty much yeah two couples that they
take well wait a minute like brooke
adams is in this and this might be her
first role or her first leading role if
you don't know brooke adams is she was
in dead zone and she was in um
invasion of the body snatchers only like
a year or two after this she played
chris the philippi member girlfriend in
the dead zone yeah yeah she was in a
[ __ ] ton of movies she's probably maybe
19 or 20 in the booth yeah she's very
young in this so i kind of feel like
this was maybe her major i mean because
she's like a big character in this yeah
and she actually kind of carries the
movie she's one she's probably one of
the better actors in the movie besides
uh the nazi [ __ ] uh uh [ __ ]
admiral or just peter pushing her peter
[ __ ] cushing yeah he's in it uh but
she spends a lot of time just [ __ ]
being herself and acting and running
around in her [ __ ] bikini in a yellow
bikini so yeah
she'll have a shirt on but of course the
big teeny cops underneath that's way out
to let you know do you want me to button
this shirt yeah yeah yeah absolutely
please
run through the jungle yes
and she's just you know let those
boobies bounce yeah
making money that's what they hired her
for for the movie and uh i always liked
brooke adams she was like yeah she's a
good job
yeah and then uh
her boyfriend's in it he's just kind of
like this uh typical 70s uh
dude with a stash with a porn stash see
that's not her boyfriend though that's a
that's the crew guy oh it's a crew guy
yeah because he's like remember he's
like the second in command captain
whatever the boyfriend got killed right
i don't think she had a boyfriend i
think she was just on there like by
herself wasn't she i thought maybe
because she was kind of like making the
moves on uh porn stacks yeah i guess so
yeah so i think she was there by herself
yeah and then there was another couple
with them who's the the dude the dude of
the couple is just the biggest douche
norman norman cause of course his name
is yeah norman's uptight he's like a
[ __ ] male karen i was just gonna say
i think i even called him karen when we
were watching the video like put a sock
in it karen yeah he's kind of like the
uh comedic relief he's like your
standard issue dick and [ __ ] but he
is he's in there for comedic relief and
he's got those [ __ ] those [ __ ]
plaid shorts yeah sure with the with the
izod shirt tucked into it and the boat
shoes with no socks yeah and he's got
glasses and he's kind of dumpy yeah and
he's just one of those uptight douche
and he just keeps coming in trying to
tell everybody else well i don't think
the people that are running this [ __ ]
know what's going on they don't even
know how to boil water much less saline
blah blah so i'm just like when is this
guy going to get eaten by an anaconda
come on step it up
his girlfriend is kind of like a short
blonde
that's his wife i guess his wife yeah
short blonde she at first seems to be
kind of like in her 40s but
when you when you actually as the movie
[ __ ] goes on you realize no she's
actually young she's
probably late 20s early 30s she's just
she just looks old because she's had to
put up with his crap for so long
they tried they tried to frump her out
to make her look middle-aged but uh nah
she's not middle-aged and she's kind of
cute and you know they were just didn't
want you to realize that i could think
in the beginning you know it is they
used to
[ __ ] dress certain women uh dress
them to to appear older than they were
in these movies yeah this is the middle
aged house for out even though she's
obviously like 22. exactly
that's somebody's friend they wanted her
they wanted her in the movie yeah she
was cute so but they just had to frump
her up uh but she didn't
still did a good job in a movie
um having to put up with norman yeah
[ __ ] norman well the ship kata
basically ends up getting shipwrecked i
guess well it's kind of like a death
ship situation in the sense that
well weird [ __ ] starts happening first
right because at first it's like daytime
and they're all you know it's it's like
a pleasure cruise ship but it's kind of
a janky one yeah like a three hour two
yeah it's one of those kind of
situations and so they're out on that
thing
i guess it's supposed to be the
caribbean or the gulf of mexico or
whatever and then um they never really
say it doesn't matter it's florida it's
fl but it's florida that's where they
shot it and uh
so so like weird [ __ ] starts happening
at first because remember like the sun
goes all yellow yeah and like the
lighting goes real funny and like all
the crew are kind of like what the [ __ ]
i've never seen anything like this
before it's super weird but then john
carradine is like what's everybody
getting all excited about it's just some
[ __ ] stuff from under the ocean
you know what i mean so it's like that
and then but still like the other
courage is like yeah but still though
and then they're there in the middle of
the night and then they hear something
weird and then it looks like
a big ghost ship a la death ship goes by
them yeah and hit grazes and kind of
grazes the ship yeah
um but then like when everybody comes
out like with the lights and the flares
and everything they don't see it all
they see is this really really old wreck
and the captain's gone that's like far
away yeah and then they can't well the
next morning they can't find the captain
they can't find john carradine
so um
never really explained they do find him
not really so he's i mean because john
carradine does kind of like laugh at
other people it's like why do you think
there's a ghost ship out there
you know so it's that kind of thing
but because he does see a ship like porn
stash sees the ship right but then when
they look at the lights it's not there's
a ship but it's like a wreck and it's
obviously not moving oh and i forgot to
tell you this whole movie is a flashback
see now i think that was and i watched
some other reviews of it and they're
just kind of like why the [ __ ] did they
do that because it's like you know
you know spoiler alert like i said for a
movie that's from 1977 from when i was
five years old um you know that brooke
adams character is gonna live because
she they sure because she's the one
telling that she's the one that gets
rescued at the end and she's the only
one there she's the final girl again
she's like she's like the [ __ ]
ancient mariner out of the rhyming
story this is what happened yeah it
starts off with [ __ ] voiceovers and
world war [ __ ] two photos of german
soldiers saying you know that there was
a an elite
german unit that was so bad they just
fought with their hands and they fought
with their hands and their feet i guess
no weapons and they never surrendered
never didn't catch them they just kicked
people in the shot yeah
yeah they were the only like what did
they say the only german unit that like
didn't like in world war ii that didn't
have any of their members captured at
any point so they're kind of like
they're going the german like the nazi
super soldier route yeah super soldier
rap right we're super soldiers yeah
but also kind of like undead yeah they
said they weren't alive and they weren't
dead they were super soldiers because
peter cushing kind of
starts exposited you that and then you
see a woman in a dinghy who survived and
this uh
like he's a black dude and his [ __ ]
son pull her out [ __ ] give her some
water they pull her out of the dinghy
they're in a boat and uh fisherman and
the dude's doing kind of like a pretty
bad jamaican accent you know it's a he's
from florida yeah i couldn't figure out
if it was can you talk like a jamaican
see i thought it might have been haitian
dominican republic you know where are
where are we now you know but it didn't
really sound like any of those
so i'm not sure if it's just a dude from
florida it was different that said i'm
just gonna give like a generic sort of
caribbean kind of sounding accent i'm
not really sure it was good though you
know what i mean they're just
entertaining you this is [ __ ] florida
this is florida man made this movie
they did actually
made this movie
this great movie though so then get to
get back to the thing [ __ ] uh somehow
the nazis the the the aquatic nazis
[ __ ] grabbed the captain and the ship
and did it run aground
i think it did yeah run aground i mean
they didn't show that because budget but
they did tell peter cushing later that
they somehow lost that they said yeah we
ran aground ran aground so then they get
in little [ __ ] dinghies and go they
they they uh
are able to get to shore
and dude climbs up a [ __ ] tree to get
a coconut
and seize the top of this [ __ ]
beautiful spanish building off in the
distance
stick it out of the jungle
and they walk to it and it's the hotel
we're talking about that's where this
movie takes place in this and it's a
beautiful
old school
spanish
hotel
it's in kind of 1800s late 1800s
architectural style with big sweeping
um arches and huge columns and it's all
stone it looks like something out of
mexico city
or you know madrid or something way back
in the day yeah it's fantastic yeah you
expected damn [ __ ] church bells on
the top of it i think there was a bell
in it when there might have been i'd
have to like look because there was a oh
can i just say that the guy that climbed
up the tree to to look across the island
um was it me or did that dude look just
like john mcenroe back in the 70s
yeah he had that like brillo hair type
yeah situation going on they all had
perms a little bit well a little bit
like art garfunkel too but not quite as
like you know crazy or like as high
volume as that
so they get into this hotel there's palm
fronds everywhere it's kind of [ __ ]
abandoned and they're checking it out
like what the [ __ ] is this place what's
it doing out here you know
they go into the kitchen and it's all
covered in dust but they find it they
find an aquarium a bunch of tropical
fish in it that are alive they're alive
live
and uh they're like they don't say
anything but then
they find this old man living out there
it's peter cushing and he's all [ __ ]
like dashing survivor with his [ __ ]
you know brown
i guess tattered uniform and his damn
necklace
and he's taking over the hotel and they
they find the main room where he is his
office is you know he's got a whole
[ __ ] wall filled with mirrors he's
got his dab which he got from the rooms
i guess and then they uh he's got his
desk there and a big old [ __ ]
swastika
and he's just being prussian as a
[ __ ] you know he's and and
they're like well what happened to you
you know and he
he went out he did he didn't tell him
right off what was going on he didn't
want to talk to him
at first he was just kind of like yeah
you guys got to get out of here like
it's not safe or something like that but
then like after a little while he's like
oh well i told you to leave and you
didn't so it's too late now and then
they were just kind of like yo we said
that our boat ran around so we're kind
of stuck here until we get some help but
then like he told him the total story he
said he was a commander of this elite
unit of submarine crew and uh
well he wasn't there commander was he he
just they they he was in charge of him
but i don't think he's originally their
commander he had a regular boat didn't
he
yeah i think he did that's what it was
he had a cargo ship and they put him on
the cargo ship they were they were
originally from a submarine
and when the war ended he couldn't drop
he couldn't get him back
uh so he i think he he ran the ship
aground and and uh he looked and sank it
he sunk the boat
and uh left them in it
and uh yeah
so they were all kind of like just in
suspended animation in there or
something like that even though he said
they still like kind of walked around
and [ __ ] but you see them every now and
then see the reason they were developed
yeah to be aquatic zombies
or vampires or whatever was so that you
could put them in a submarine and they
wouldn't ever have to surface i guess
yeah they'd live in there forever so
they could just live in there forever
and they just like lived forever so they
were underwater yeah so they were kind
of like which is such a weird idea but
um they didn't need food they didn't
need oxygen yeah so they would so
sometimes they'd be like you go they'd
go down to the beach and there'd be
little pools and they'd just be nazis
just laying in the pool with their their
like uh goggles on and [ __ ] like that
well see i think peter cushing said i
don't know if he was their commander or
whatever but they said they made all of
these and then
they couldn't uh control them yeah
because i'm like well duh you should
have thought of that let's let's see
let's make these murdery undead yeah
aquatic monsters essentially they said
they were using them on the eastern
front and then oh no we can't control
them who would have thought yeah so
they'd eventually get into a bloodlust
and they would uh kill they'd kill
german troops too
so i just didn't discriminate yeah but
the ones he was evidently given they had
they were for a submarine
but they weren't in a submarine he had
him in a cargo ship and he ended up
scuttling the cargo ship and sending
them to the bottom
but the cargo ship was i guess i guess
the water wasn't deep anymore because
the ship he's talking about is clearly
visible
yeah at least most of it was yeah and
that seems to be the cargo ship that
they ran into yeah not real clear the
ghost ship in the middle of the night
so um
as the story goes on [ __ ] happens and
this happens and this happens i i kind
of can't couldn't keep track of
everything that was happening but they
started getting attacked by the zombies
mostly people just ran around people ran
around
i gotta say
you can really tell that this is pretty
low budget
then uh
peter cushing tries to make contact with
the zombies they won't talk to him
they're they'll walk off down into the
water there are some pretty spooky shots
and when you see them and you're like
what the [ __ ] you know what i mean when
i was a kid that scared the [ __ ] out of
me they were [ __ ] spooky there were
some kind of like creepy scenes of this
yeah now when you look at them now
uh they're kind of funny they got
[ __ ] real bleach blonde hair and
[ __ ] goggles it looked like some
amount of craft work that's what i said
i was good i was gonna say that like
when we were watching see he stole my
jokes so we were
like we were watching the movie last
night i'm like look it's watercraft
first yeah
they're all like coming out of there i
think you said something about them
looking like [ __ ] sprockets
[Laughter]
looking for them
and
they don't the problem with them is that
um they got they got them in [ __ ]
like vermont outfits not submarine
outfits they're they're [ __ ] dressed
as german infantry you know
and then uniforms look brand new so
they've been sitting underneath the
water for 30 years and a [ __ ] not as
not a
not a bit of damage on the uniforms they
should have been in rags and they should
have been submarine dressed as like
submarine crew i would think
or you know some well you kind of when
your movie only costs 150 000 you kind
of have to take what you can get you
know what i mean it's like we need to go
to the costume shop and rent some nazi
uniforms can we get this wet yeah like
yeah fine um you know what i mean so
yeah i don't know but well like you said
if they'd done them in rags then they
wouldn't even necessarily have to look
that much like nazi uniforms because you
could just like make them all in right
the audience probably doesn't know what
a damn german that's what i'm saying
it's not like nowadays where everyone's
gonna nitpick you know what i mean back
then they're just like nazis yeah just
doing it
[Laughter]
and uh
and they're wearing [ __ ]
german [ __ ] army boots you know
they're basically marlboros [ __ ]
they're like english riding boots and
that was pretty much early in the war
and they said they were late war but
anyway i'm picking [ __ ] you know
that's that's what i mean that's um
you're well actually in this man well i
actually
they wouldn't have been wearing those
boots but
i kind of liked the scenes where the
where the water nazis like woke up first
and then they were just like walking
across the bottom of the
of the
shipwreck and stuff i thought that was
kind of cool yeah
they um there were some cool shots and
uh there was here's the weird thing
about this movie it's not graphic at all
no no there's no they don't even show
any of the deaths really most people are
killed off screen and then they find the
body yeah and the bodies aren't [ __ ]
up or anything no they just drowned the
drought um
so you know that they didn't have the
budget to actually
uh flick a show and i think they i i
don't think they wanted an r rating
yeah because this is pg it's pg i think
it's pg all right so it's more of a
thriller
you know what you know what's weird this
movie it's not the same
but it gave me the vibe
the same vibe as i got from let's scare
jessica to death i don't remember that
one um it has kind of like and almost
that and this is gonna sound shitty
because this is a lot this is like a
hundred times better but it also
reminded me of
blood waters of dr z i don't remember
that otherwise known as uh
zat
if you've seen it it was on mystery
science theater that was also shot in
florida matter of fact uh that movie
like i said is about 100 times shittier
than this one it probably cost like a
buck 98 to make um so this one's better
than that but this one kind of it struck
me as somewhere on a continuum between
blood waters of dr z
and let's scare jessica to death you
know what i'm saying because it's it's
it's florida it has that aquatic kind of
setting and it almost has
like a lot of the shots of the nazis
like coming out of the water and stuff
like that and there's not really any
score
and it kind of has that weird like dream
like
surreal kind of vibe to it and i don't
even think it was intentional it just
kind of happened yeah so that's maybe
that's why i'm kind of like feeling
those two movies you know what i'm
saying yeah there's a bunch of good
comments and questions in there you can
read
where uh where was that somebody said
somebody in this movie was in flipper
which got which person yeah i don't i
haven't seen flippers since i was little
so i don't even like remember
interestingly the guy that directed this
uh ken wiederhorn weirderhorn readerhom
i looked him up
and he was mostly like um like a news
and documentary guy like he made those
uh but he did tv too he did like later
on he did like 21 jump street and like
some of uh freddie's nightmares remember
that show like the freddie the offshoot
of the thing but probably he didn't do
that many movies he did this one which
is his first one i think and then he did
return of the living dead part two uh
which you know was pretty decent and
then he did meatballs too and a couple
of other ones i remember the first
meatballs i don't really remember the
second one i probably saw it but like i
said i think this might have been the
first
i know that there was like a whole like
there was a bunch of nazi exploitation
movies in the 70s like you know
she wolf of the ss and all that ilsa
but
this might have been the first nazi
zombies i think it was i mean if i'm not
missing even though they're not
technically zombies like they don't eat
people
they don't they don't really do anything
they just kill people
they drown people they are undead though
yeah but but evidently they were made
out of dead soldiers they were brought
back to life so it was technology it
wasn't
yeah although it may i think i think
okay
i think they i think it might have been
some occult powers because i think that
might have been mentioned in because i
didn't read about the production of the
movie
uh the people that produced it didn't
have any money so they immediately
wanted a damn horror movie and then the
people who wrote up about it said well
okay yeah
throw nazis in there too
yeah cause they're like well we can
shoot in florida and water is scary
that's true scary nazis and hey nazis
let's throw some nazis in there you get
a good mileage out of nazis so it was a
kind of a shake and bake project but
for 150 000 this movie [ __ ] worked i
think it did
and i remember watching this on cable
back in california and my uncle red from
mount mountain poultry guys liked it he
liked us he this is this scared him
because he was in his 20s like oh man
that's [ __ ]
up you they had stuff like that i mean
they're making a movie about it
they're making a movie about it
therefore it must be real they knew they
knew some harry potter movies would like
a word with you yeah
you knew something about it they must
have been dude they were doing weird
stuff back then you know
it's like super soldier serum you know
that's uh you know
things are kind of inspired by well
didn't they say didn't this because now
i'm kind of like confusing it because we
watched death ship in this movie in the
same like uh you know the same two
nights
didn't wasn't there like a little bit of
a thing at the beginning of this one
that said there were like some kind of
like energy from the center of the earth
yeah they said energy from the center of
the earth right that they said that
right thrilled real they're talking
about braille yeah so it's it's so it's
like magic somebody did there did did
their homework this was like nazis at
the center of the earth you know real
energy
which if you haven't seen nazis at the
center of the earth please see that it's
so funny that's the one of the good
asylum
if you don't under don't know german
science fiction
um
there was a book called vril the coming
power some translations are vril the
coming race
and it was about a race of beings that
lived in a hollow earth
uh and they powered their technology and
their magic through some kind of a power
that they called vril
now vril
maybe
the force okay and george lucas kind of
based the force on yin yang and the
germanic
version of yin yang
would have been the will
the will and uh because
the will was arthroscopic excuse me was
the will was um
friedrich nietzsche but also kind of
arthur scopenhauer also talked about the
will
and
they're talking about
uh the force the force basically and
that there's two sides of it a negative
and a positive side destruction and
creation yin and yang
so
whoever wrote this movie at least knew a
little bit about
german science fiction and german
philosophy now the reason why that's
kind of been linked with the nazis is uh
because nazis were made up of german
people ain't that something and these
german people like read german science
fiction
and science fiction
always had an influence on on
on people
a lot of the things about the third
right were science fiction
from the german point of view
fourth jar down says the village the the
village people right they're privileged
people oh my god that that's like really
funny but um it's the same with the
other kind of socialists [ __ ] they
were in science fiction too socialism
national socialism international social
was always science fiction uh
hg wells
he was big into that um
what was the other one uh like shape of
things to come
that's h2o
yeah she wills yeah and then who is the
other guy
jules verne jules verne all right all
the fabian socialists from england
uh were
it is science fiction futurism futurism
that's a good way to put it futurism so
they talk about real so you're right
well what the i mean what the director
of this was talking about was that i
think he initially got the idea to do
nazis because he was he was reading a
book or knew somebody that was reading a
book um about the third rank and about
their whole occult thing yeah called the
morning of the magicians okay yeah so uh
so that's kind of where so i don't know
if he it wasn't real clear whether he
said he had read it or he knew somebody
that read it and told him about it i
haven't read that particular book but
just to warn any listeners don't read
any of those old books about german
occultism and the nazis because
some of them were good most of them were
totally made up out of thin air
so you have to be careful what you're
reading and
like for instance the nazi bell thing
made up out of thin air pretty much
that didn't
i don't believe the nazi bell existed
um it's a neat story neat story but
there was a lot of old books
a lot of them appeared in the 60s and
the 70s
that made claims that the germans were
doing certain things and there may have
been some
some records saying yeah this person was
here at a particular time and this is
but there's but they're talking about
the bell and there's no evidence for any
kind of [ __ ] belt made up
so yeah so they this didn't actually
come out until 1977. again i think it
was a pretty limited release even though
they shot it in 1975
and the original title which actually i
think is a better title none of them
think about it was death core
um
which maybe is better because one shock
waves doesn't make any sense no with
what and in the uk it was released as
almost human okay which
although you know that doesn't really
sound like a horror movie it was almost
human with an exclamation point
i think i think what they're talking
about from the american to the american
title shock waves might have been pretty
might have been good waves it's the
water shock
death core death troops shock troops you
know what i mean yeah i guess like yeah
i see where they were going with that
i'm talking about i get where they were
going with that death troops from the
underneath the waves i think is what
they're talking about
shock waves to me sounds more like like
electrical shields it does it does so
that's kind of why i think i think
they're talking about shock troops from
underneath the waves that's what yeah i
get that but
yeah i don't i don't think that's an
association that's kind of like a that's
a couple steps
removed they played around with those
words then well what's the shock waves
it's shocking
yes
shocking shock troops from underneath
the waves see now if the nazis had some
kind of like electrical real power and
shocked people to death yeah yeah then
see that would have been a really good
time it might have been originally in
the idea maybe but they didn't do that
they both they basically just drown
people yeah they didn't kill anybody
other than drowning them
in the epilogue or prologue the
beginning is the prologue or the
epilogue the prologue the prologue
epilogue's at the end at the end that's
right prologue in the prologue it
mentions brill so
it may have been i don't think it says
that word but it says
it talks about the power but that's what
they're talking about that's what
they're talking about and maybe they
were gonna have it so they threw
lightning bolts or through
or did something yeah did something to
somebody
cool now but maybe they couldn't afford
the effect so they had to i'm imagining
because i mean even in the mid 70s 150
000 to make a movie was like nothing
well we don't know what the death scenes
look like because it's always the
aftermath you never really see them yeah
anybody it could have been they were
grabbing people and they were like ah
dying
that way yeah that's true yeah i mean
but then it didn't look good so they cut
it out so you never got to see it
yeah so it just so it just looked like
everybody drowned yeah because maybe
they were going to add an effect
like like yeah a shot like you know blue
glowing effects or lightning bolt type
effects and they didn't have the money
to add the effect so they kicked they
just said [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
and i was shocked to have that effect
how much you want to bet that's why they
wouldn't show it
but like i said can we just talk a
little bit about how
because brooke adams character her
name's rose right i think it was rose
i just call her brooke adams but um
because she's kind of famous so uh so
she kind of accidentally discovers that
all you have to do is take off their
goggles and they die yeah they just like
lay down and die and their face well
wait did they did their faces get a
little more rotted looking yeah it did
okay things kind of they kind of rotted
up a little so like i said that's kind
of like they're sort of like vampires
too because they're kind of like
sleeping like under the water all the
time and then they get like activated
for some reason but they the weird thing
is like they're so the sunlight you're
presuming is what killed them maybe but
so i was like why are they walking
around in the daytime
seeing the light killed them
okay
they can look at the they can look at
the sun with the goggles with the
goggles but when the goggles weren't
there i guess it you're
you're
you're reading too much into it i'm a
writer you're a writer i guarantee i
think about these kind of things the
screenwriter should too yeah
i guarantee you i guarantee you what
they did was is they said well hold on
one second
if these things are such badasses and
the american soldiers couldn't kill them
and they could kill people with you know
with their bare hands you know run
through machine gun fire and kill people
with their bare hands how do these
[ __ ] off this boat kill them right oh
well they they got goggles on them so
why are there goggles on these damn
things it's because if you take the
goggles off they see something like one
weakness
so their only chance is to take the damn
goggles off that's an ed wood solution i
mean it's fair it's not necessarily
something that you would think of no you
wouldn't think of it but it's it's ed
it's ed wood technology it is hey here i
got an idea if they take the goggles off
they die
and maybe nobody ever got close enough
to them to take the goggles off so no
one discovered this uh well a couple
guys this achilles heel a couple guys no
i'm just saying previous previous
previews yeah i guess because like i
said it just happened that like brooke
adams what was like struggling with one
of them and happened to take him off and
she's like oh well yeah
it is yeah
dramatic music gets played in the
[ __ ] you know what's weird though
that she did that and then
immediately you would think that she
would immediately run and go you
actually got you guys i figured out how
to kill him but i don't think she told
them yeah it's like she's like she
didn't understand what she saw
maybe she didn't understand like why
then she's like oh well maybe he just
got old and died
i don't know but it's like because i was
expecting her to run in and tell them
hey all you have to do is like whip
their [ __ ] goggles off and they'll
just like keel over but i don't think
she ever told them they don't die
immediately remember they just let you
go and stagger off yeah they're just
they die they die later yeah
and then they yeah and then like later
on they looked out and they saw it oh
can we talk too about
uh the john mcenroe looking [ __ ]
who like when there's only four of them
left alive three of them left alive porn
stash john mcenroe no there's four of
them brook adams and uh norman's
long-suffering wife and so they're
trying to hide from the water nazis
and they
shut themselves in a refrigerator at
which point
the john mcenroe looking [ __ ]
has a wig out now he doesn't say that
he's like claustrophobic i'm assuming
that that's what it was
but he was like flipping out somebody's
like let me out let me out and he was
like gonna shoot them yeah i'm like what
you want to go get eaten by water nazis
rather than like sitting in a
refrigerator which was really not that
small it's like you're not in a coffin
calm down yeah but yeah he just he had a
[ __ ] freak out and i think he even
like set off um a flare
inside there right yeah which you know
so there was that 789 tundra said that
this is truly a terrifying
you know i will i will agree that day
it's a weird idea and like some of the
imagery like especially like the nazis
coming out of the water and like and the
the lack of score like is kind of creepy
yeah and it does have some creepy images
says that he's seen it in the [ __ ] it
was it was at the drive-in all the time
he saw it a couple times three foot two
three times it it you gotta remember
it's not a graphic movie yeah there's
hardly there's no blood there's nothing
like that it's not real it's not gory
nope uh it's just
it tries to scare you without having any
money behind it and no special effects
so it's p i think it's pg rated i think
it is too um
i didn't it didn't even have any nudity
in it did it
no all right so just bouncing bikini
boobies when i was a kid it scared the
[ __ ] out of us and an adult
it's funny it is a fun watch
if you drink yeah i kind of feel like
the only thing i mean you can really
tell like i said more power to you if
you can make a [ __ ] movie a retro for
you know that's even mildly entertaining
you know good for you because it's like
really difficult
but um it's a little i will say that you
can it it's lack of budget really kind
of shows cause particularly in the
middle and even toward the end it gets a
little baggy yeah in the sense that
they're like well we need to make this
90 minutes or however long it was 18
minutes so so there's like lots and lots
of scenes of people just like running
through the swamps
like away from the nazis there's like a
lot of that i always have a feeling that
it's happening right at right outside
disney world
and michael caine's [ __ ] didn't hear
from the from the from well where they
shot it was pretty much right outside
miami it was just like a big swampy park
in miami somewhere but it's it's it's a
super good entertaining
retro
mid 70s florida movie and i mean you
can't go wrong with peter cushing right
now and john carradine too yeah he's
although he gets killed pretty easily
he's got a couple cute girls in it and
and a bunch of zombies i mean you know
what more could a guy with with a
drinking his head ask for
when it comes to retro set these movies
and it's got a lot it's got a lot of
kind of like
half-assed dialogue
it doesn't have any score that i
remember it doesn't have any score does
it just that's what i was thinking
that's why it kind of gave me that
theory let's scare jessica to death vibe
because that kind of had some music in
it too but a lot of it didn't so they
had like a lot of these really weird
because let's scare jessica to death
also had that scene where the vampire
lady was like coming out of the water
and it was like silent and it was like
really creepy so this has like a lot of
shots like that yeah so it's a creepy
idea like these dudes just like walking
around in the [ __ ] and honestly i
gotta say like the cast
did they probably didn't get paid much
yeah um and man they were troopers
because i'm sure it was like 4 billion
degrees and i'm sure they were getting
eaten alive by mosquitoes and there was
alligators and water moccasins and all
kind of crap snapping turtles the movie
to me is in the spirit of death ship
similar to death ship although death
ship is a lot higher end yeah until
there's a lot more money in death ship
um
tone tonally
kind of almost like a cheaper version of
night of living dead did you notice yeah
kind of like like the first night of the
living dead yeah i would put it there
with that
but color
uh
but they're attempting the same thing
they're trying to make a zombie movie
for no money
and make it interesting yeah and i think
they pretty much do it yeah um
i mean definitely if you like nazi
exploitation movies and you like like a
kind of a quirky
weird eerie yeah
yeah it's a little bit surreal it is it
has a little bit of an italian one if
you ask me well it depends it depends on
what on what you're looking for i guess
the the italian ones tend to be a lot
more gory a lot more gory yeah so if
that's so if you want to see people's
eyeballs get gashed out and everybody's
intestines falling out and [ __ ] like
that then yeah you got to watch the
italian ones because this one is like
there's no blood in this at all no no to
me it's like um
nazi zombies
night in the living dead the first one
and the very first friday the 13th
it's that kind of low budget but even
lower budget
there's there's no gore in it
which in a way kind of makes it
acceptable
for kids in a world in a weird way it'll
scare the [ __ ] out of kids and not show
them a drop of blue i guess i mean